[Musique]
mes parents avait 18 ans quand ils m'ont
eu
et comme il n'avait pas le temps passer
du temps avec moi
eh bien il me mettait dans la télé quand
je n'étais pas à l'école je crois que je
suis la personne qui a passé plus de
temps devant la télé au monde
mais quelle chance quelle chance parce
que de srec à 15 ans j'ai tout appris
via le petit écran tout j'ai grandi avec
casimir
j'ai été amoureuse d'albator puis plus
tard de magnum et puis mon père de
substitution est et colombo ça l'est
toujours mais surtout je me souviens
d'un truc très important pour moi c'est
que j'ai réussi à enlever les petites
routes mon vélo grâce à une petite
cuillère et surtout à mac gyver
bref vous l'aurez compris pour moi ce
soir c'était très important de vous
parler de ce qui m'a construite ce qui a
rythmé ma vie et qui l'a rythme encore
aujourd'hui et séries télé alors qu'on
les aime ou non les séries télé sont le
reflet de notre époque
vous n'avez pas me dire le contraire
mais surtout elles sont le reflet notre
intimité profonde parce que nous nous
identifions à leur héros parce que nous
comprenons leur héros parce que nous
vivons avec leurs héros et donc quand on
les regarde de très près on se rend
compte de ce qui va ou de ce qui ne va
pas chez nous ils nous passent des
messages sur nous mêmes et justement
quand on regarde ces héros de série très
près on se rend compte qu'il ya eu trois
périodes trois grandes périodes dans les
séries télé et dans les héros de séries
télé qui nous ont distillé trois grands
types de messages mais pas sur n'importe
qui sur nous mêmes d'abord il ya eu les
premiers héros de séries de 1950 à 2000
et ses héros de série là il était
antilles il était sympa il sauver le
monde
il est le bien je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez sorcière bien aimée superman
friends tout ça vous connaissez et
pourquoi il sauver le monde pourquoi il
faisait le bien ces héros de séries télé
parce que le monde était déjà bien était
déjà un monde dans lequel le bien le mal
était fixé et donc le bien le mal était
fixé la justice était la justice on
savait ce que c'était donc tout était
bien à sa place donc le rôle des héros
de série à l'époque c'était quoi c'était
de nous montrer que c'était tout était
possible et qu'il fallait aller encore
plus loin qu'il fallait nous dépasser et
justement à cette époque je me souviens
aussi
moi j'étais dans une agence de pub et je
me prenais pour amanda woodward dans
melrose place bon ça c'était la première
catégorie de héros qui nous ont dit ma
le monde est génial donc soyez encore
plus génial que lui deuxième catégorie
de héros 2001 2015 et là ça se gâte
ça se gâte parce que l'amérique qui
était la grande fabrique de gentils
héros de super u de héros à super
pouvoir tombe et elle tombe deux fois en
2001 et en 2008 avec la faillite de
lehman brothers la banque est donc là on
remet tout en question
on se dit mais attends c'est quoi le
bien c'est quoi le mal la justice on me
parlait de justice mais la sq ya une
justice réellement et puis si jamais
c'est tout ça se bouscule tout ça est
dans un gros chaos
pourquoi à la télévision on devrait
regarder des gentils héros alors que ce
sont les pourris qui gagne dans la vraie
vie gros chaos grosse période de
questionnement et les héros change de
super gentil avec des super pouvoirs
il passa super pourri dexter dr house et
ça c'est pour les plus sympas
cohabitent avec walter white sais pas si
vous le connaissez dealer producteurs de
méthamphétamine père de famille puis
tueur breaking bad donc série super
carton puis un tout petit peu plus tard
game of thrones roi sanguinolent qui
s'entretuent tranquille on les regarde
tranquille et pour qu'on regarde
tranquille et bien parce que on a plus
confiance dans l'eau valeur et puis
surtout parce que tout ce qu'on avait
planqué sous le tapis dans les années 80
le matérialisme les l'humanité l'égoïsme
l'individualisme et ben sanou zerbaz ça
nous rebat ça nous ça nous faisait
rebalancer et avec un effet boomerang
terrible et heureusement
heureusement il ya une troisième
catégorie de héros qui arrive depuis
cette nouvelle catégorie de héros sont
des héros humains et équilibrée alors
quand je dis équilibré vous pensez tout
de suite les gens bien carrées et pas du
tout équilibrées ça veut dire plein de
failles de toc de névroses de doute mais
aussi d'idéaux comme nous et ses rôles à
tout d'un coup ils bouleversent
l'univers des séries télé il bouleverse
lainière déshérités parce qu'en 2016
c'est l'élection de donald trump et
cette élection fait que on se demande
tous jusqu'où va aller le mal et que
peut-être il faut revenir à une certaine
humanité et donc on commence à voir
arriver des héros du type el profesor le
chef de gang de braqueurs de gaza des
papes elle qui est pas mieux que les
autres mais qui est plus humain quand
même qui presque plus humain que les
zotac ils les otages qu'ils gardent dans
tout ça cependant cette troisième
catégorie deux héros on doit se poser
une seule question cette question c
pourquoi les scénaristes se met à nous
faire regarder des gens normaux dans des
vies normales
pourquoi est en fait la réponse est
assez simple elle est simple parce que
finalement si on regarde nos réalités
nous nous rendons compte que nous
étouffons nous et nous étouffons dans
des réalités qui sont presque plus
fictionnel que les histoires
aujourd'hui facebook instagram les
réseaux sociaux nous font faire en sorte
que nous nous mettons en scène en
permanence nous ne cherchons à nous
sublimer en permanence nous cherchons à
avoir des notre objectif premier c'est
d'avoir des likes non c'est nous
socialiser au travers de tous ces
réseaux
et pourtant pourtant les héros de séries
nous disent linverse pourtant les héros
de séries en nous montrant des gens qui
sont totalement normaux nous
réapprennent à vivre normalement et nous
il nous rappelle une quelque chose de
fondamental qui est que pour être le
héros de sa vie il faut en être le
personnage principal ça veut dire quoi
le personnage principal de sa vie
ça veut dire celui qui choisit ça veut
dire celui qui choisit en connaissance
de cause ça veut dire qu'ils celui qui
choisit non pas en regardant et en
écoutant les aphorismes que l'on peut
lire sur internet sur la réussite le
bonheur du type mettez tous les efforts
dans ce qui est important pour vous mark
zuckerberg ou encore soyez lettres
révèlent être dont vous rêvez dès à
présent tenir robbins c'est pas choisir
ses aphorismes c'est faire comme frank
and woods le héros de house of cards qui
au lieu de choisir sa vraie sexualité
choisira d'être le président des états
unis parce qu'il ne peut pas assumer sa
vraie sexualité est alors donc en
cela il nous questionne sur ce que nous
sommes prêts à sacrifier de nous-mêmes
pour atteindre nos objectifs être le
héros de sa vie les séries nous disent
que c'est être celui qui ressent celui
qui peut être déstabilisé comme les
protagonistes de sensei tu la série qui
a fait un carton
pendant deux ans ses protagonistes il
nous encourage à vivre nos émotions des
émotions même négative parce que la peur
la colère et la tristesse nous font
accéder à ce qui est important à ce qui
est le fondamental pour un être humain
sa singularité
parce que c'est sa singularité qui va
lui permettre de se rapprocher des gens
qui lui ressemble
et puis ces héros de séries nous disent
que pour être le héros de sa vie être le
héros de sa vie c'est aussi peut-être
être un marginal impôts mais quelqu'un
qui n'est pas bien dans sa peau mais qui
va apporter tellement au monde comme le
héros de mister robote elliott dépressif
paranoïaque hors cadre mais aussi génie
de l'informatique qui va sauver la
société en luttant contre ses troubles
de la personnalité
en nous montrant elliott les nouveaux
héros de série nous montre que pour
trouver sa voie il faut trouver sa voie
une voie à sa lumière mais aussi à son
ombre je pourrais vous citer tellement
d'autres exemples puisque je voulais dit
je suis une enfant de la télé est pour
moi la fiction c'est plus court chemin
vers la réalité une réalité réussit donc
il me semblait très important ce soir de
relayer un message que nous donne que
nous distille les nouveaux super héros
des séries télé qui est soyons vivants
soyons un parfait osons être des freaks
pour montrer nos singularités soyons
humains et normaux tout simplement
il est temps de regarder
et d'écouter ces nouveaux héros de
séries télé pour mieux vivre nos vies
réelles
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à